hey i'm luke hemmings and i'm here with
buzzfeed to talk about my first times
been practicing that all morning lock it
in
the first song i ever wrote okay for the
longest time when i was like 12 to 14. i
was like or even earlier than that i was
trying to write songs and i can never
quite complete them and always being
like oh i don't know if this is good
enough or whatever so the first person i
finished a full song with is callum from
five sauce he was better than me and he
helped me finish our first song i think
it would have been out of my limit on
the first ep of the band first time i
was on stage oh geez would have been in
high school i would have been very
nervous very sweaty oh geez i think i
played i'm yours jason mraz remember
that was like the biggest song of all
time i mean it still is i guess first
talent show i think i got third i think
i peru deserved third i definitely
didn't deserve first maybe even not even
the third i shouldn't have got that
maybe my mom had a word with them first
memory on tour with five sauce when we
first started as a band we were in high
school together so we would play shows
on the weekend and then we'd come back
to school that was kind of the first
memory like going to melbourne and uh
like brisbane and then we went to new
zealand for the first time that was red
i mean i was like 15 so it was the
coolest thing ever it was at a point
like we played big school shows they
weren't big at all you know just like me
an acoustic guitar so when we started
the band and like you know even the
first show we played was to 12 people at
the annandale hotel including our
parents and
it was rad i mean we were terrible but
it was the best and worst gig of my life
i guess
the first song that i wrote for my new
album when facing the things we turn
away from there was a lot that didn't
make it on the album because it took me
a long time to figure out exactly what i
wanted it to sound and feel like but i
remember placing me and mum being very
very close to the start especially mum
if you listen to it it sounds pretty
pretty crazy and big and
ethereal and you know quite drama as i
can be
first time i realized i was famous i
don't know i don't think i've ever felt
like that if i'm honest and that sounds
like i'm lying but we have a lot of fans
as a band and very lucky to have like a
lot of people that support the band so
in those sort of situations like for
people at shows and singing the songs
that always feels like great but i think
on a fame level i don't think it's ever
i don't know i just have never felt like
that i feel like we just have such a
great fan base first album i ever bought
was with my own money i bought good
charlotte the young and the hopeless
which is you know very pop punk vibes
that was the second album that they ever
made and the first time i ever bought
that was the one that sort of kicked it
off i suppose and i was you know i saw
them live and i thought they were so rad
so rad i know the boys it's really weird
i tell them all the time i say you know
like i think you're my first album and
one of the first shows i ever went to
like cool i texted the other day there
it's so weird for me i'm such a big fan
still i'm a big fan first time i met my
fiance sierra we met at a gig the night
game is the name of the band that we saw
we were both really excited that there
was a dog there and yeah just really
sweet we just met through friends so it
happened really naturally almost in an
old school way first ridiculously untrue
rumor you heard about yourself i don't
know
there was one that i i don't know how i
died but i died for about an hour on
twitter i think that maybe that's a
dream though i don't know i was
obviously alive so i set the record
straight
you know first time i realized i wanted
to be a performer me and my dad used to
go to he was the one that would take me
to gigs and i saw good charlotte and i'd
seen a couple other bands i went to this
show called taste of chaos which is like
a bunch of like heavy bands and i
thought it was really rad i just thought
the whole thing was really cool that
people could i don't know go on stage
and have songs that they had written he
sung back to them because a lot of bands
and artists wouldn't come to australia
as much as other places and especially
where i grew up it was quite out of the
city it was really difficult to get to
shows and they were very expensive i
used to watch a lot of things online
like i used to watch you know classic uh
ac dc and like nxs and green day and
blink like on youtube honestly that was
a huge part of it as well just like
being extremely captivated by just
watching like a live performance as five
stars came together at such a young age
it just i don't know just all clicked
and we were just best mates and it
seemed to be resonating even on the
small level that we had and i think that
was
just something that we chased down i
mean even to this day that moment was
probably the one that obviously has made
my life very different first instrument
i learned to play was uh actually this
is strange because i was gonna say
guitar descend but i remember so i've
started playing guitar because my oldest
brother ben used to take guitar lessons
for like a month or whatever like he
wasn't super into it i guess and he had
like this run-down acoustic guitar at
the house and there was some songs in a
songbook like really simple like smoke
on the water and lester in the sun by
the violet femmes i remember playing
smoke on the water on one string for
hours and hours it's like everyone's
first guitar song but i like drums a lot
at the start i remember because my
brother other brother about two brothers
and he played drums a bunch and i
remember thinking that was really cool
and then you look up to your older
brother so i tried to play that and i
wasn't very good so i was like all right
i'm gonna play guitar and i'm probably
better at guitar at 14 than i am now
thank you buzzfeed for having me today
my first ever solo album is out now it's
called when facing the things we turn
away from and i hope you enjoy it 12
year old luke that's a pretty big step i
mean i would have been pretty smitten
with that for sure
[Music]
you